Sensory deprivation is where we put
people in dark soundproof rooms or water
tanks.
People are becoming aware that we needed
sensation,
stimulation,
variation,
all of us as much as we need to,
a float in the water and so forth.
The basic needs and deprivation of this
kind of stimulation,
uh,
lead to,
some,
uh,
very uncomfortable states.
Uh,
so we,
we asked is there a personality trait
that some people need more stimulation
or more variety or intensity of
stimulation than others.
And that's when we developed our first
sensation seeking scale.
And subsequently that expanded became
the main focus of my research is the,
uh,
we were surprised by how many things
were affected by this trait sensation
seeking.
And then we got interested in the
biological basis.
It's genetic and biological basis.
And here again,
we had some very interesting findings
pointed to the fact that this is a very
fundamental trait with biological roots.
Well,
this is determined from twin studies
called biometrics,
have a behavioral genetics actually.
Uh,
and,
uh,
using these twin studies,
we initially found that roughly 60
percent heritability heritability is the
proportion of the variance trait that's
determined by genetics.
And we discovered there was 60 percent,
which is very high for personality
trait,
which generally run between 30 and 50
percent.
So 60 percent is high for a personality
trait.
Well,
it's higher for intelligence and some
other traits.
So a little more recently,
uh,
oh,
this was established,
not only using twins are raised
together,
but twins raised apart showing that it
wasn't due to the fact of sharing a
stimulating environment.
Let's say there was an environmental
aspect of this,
of the remaining 40 percent,
some of those error of measurement,
but some of it is due to environment,
but it's not the shared where we go the
shared environment shared in the family.
It's due to the,
uh,
a non shared environment,
which means your friends,
peers,
your unique life experiences that you
have the other people in your family,
you don't share with other people in
your family.
We can surmise that the sense of
particular gene has been found to be
related to sensation seeking a dope,
mean,
receptive Jane,
so that it's been there a long time.
Well,
actually they estimate that it's not old
evolution,
you know,
maybe 50,000,
100,000
years old in our species,
uh,
this particular Jane,
but there may be other genes that are
older even,
but you see this another,
the point is you see what we might call
sensation sick analogs of sensation
seeking behavior and other species.
In fact,
a lot of my work has compared sensation
seeking a expressions exploration,
novel approach,
the novelty and other species with the
same explored this,
that the extent that they have the same
biological roots and Helen's and then
other species.
So in that sense,
we look at evolution.
We have a modern test of evolution when
you can find something that exists in
humans and earlier species,
particularly primates,
but also even in rats when you can find
this and it's linked to the same
biological indicators in both species,
in both humans and other animals that
indicates that has a revolutionary
history.
Rather,
it's more than a merely analogy,
oh,
this looks like what we do,
but it's more than that.
It's that the fact that it looks like
sensation seeking and has the same
biological roots,
I would say the,
uh,
the age differences are somewhat larger
if you're looking at the extremes.
No,
I would say like it like about 60,
65.
A male would have half the sensation
seeking store that he had when he was in
his late teens,
early twenties.
So that's pretty much of a decline.
Uh,
the male female differences are constant
across age,
uh,
but,
perhaps not as large as when we talk
about sex differences,
you know,
and traits.
We're always talking about a lot of
overlap for you about population
differences.
So people always say,
I know someone who is a female,
but it's very high sensation seeking.
Of course,
you know,
there's variation within both genders.
Just the overall population differences
different.